راويه بالفعل وصل قبل قليل اللواء ناصر
منصور هادي شقيق الرئيس السابق عبد ربه
منصور هادي الى مطعم الملك خالد الدولي في
طائره خاصه اقلته من عدن
ووصل في هذه اللحظه وكما تشاهدين هنالك
جموع من المسؤولين في الحكومه اليمنيه
وكذلك من الوزراء وكذلك من اعضاء مجلس
القياده الرئاسي يستقبلون اللواء ناصر
هادي الذي كان مقررا ان يصل في الساعه
الثالثه عصرا ولكن تاخرت الطائره الى خمسه
ساعات حيث وصل الان في الساعه التاسعه
والنصف بتوقيت الرياض الى مطار الملك خالد
الدولي وكما تشاهدين اعضاء من الحكومه
اليمنيه وشاهد وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر
الارياني وكذلك الاعضاء في مجلس القياده
الرئاسيه الذين استقبلوا اللواء الذي وصل
الان ومن المقر ايضا
راويه ان يكون ان يتم عمل فحوصات للواء
ناصر هادي مباشره فورا وصوله الان وسناخذ
الكاميرا لنذهب مع هذا الوفد الذي وصل
وبدا باستقبال
اللواء ناصر هادي حيث تحوم الشكوك راويه
حول صحه اللواء وحول مدى يعني صحته
فبالتالي سيتم عمل مباشره الاجراءات
الصحيه له في مطار الملك خالد الدولي
شاهدت العديد من التجهيزات الطبيه ايضا
بالاضافه الى سيارات الاسعاف المتواجده
للتعامل مع اي حاله صحيه للواء الذي وصل
قبل اقل من خمسه دقائق في هذه اللحظات في
مطار الملك خالد الدولي ودخل الى داخل
برفقه الوفد الذي استقبله في
المطار وعلى راسهم اعضاء مجلس القياده
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى وزراء في الحكومه
اليمنيه راويه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات